ben voilà on a atteint 100 millions de
vues cumulées sur la voilà c'est
exceptionnel
c'est fou c'est exceptionnel c'est
exceptionnel si elle me fait rien avec
continue il y a aucun problème vas-y
est-ce que vous saviez que greloter dans
le froid 15 minutes équivaut à une heure
de sport on sait le froid permet de
mieux cicatriser de calmer les douleurs
de réduire les inflammations et encore
plein de choses mais en plus d'être un
super outil thérapeutique il peut
également être un très bon allié de
remise en forme les basses températures
augmentent ce qu'on appelle le taux
métabolique c'est-à-dire le nombre de
calories que votre corps brûle au repos
mais aussi lorsque vous pratiquez une
activité physique
[Musique]
voilà des gens de tous les jours comme
vous et moi mais qui à un moment de leur
vie décide de franchir le cap de passer
de l'ombre à la lumière de tenter leur
chance de devenir des artistes alors
jamais aussi simple mais une chose est
sûre cette année on a eu un casting
absolument d'étonnant et la voix que
vous entendez le oh ouais Nikos il est
autre que celle d'Amel Bent qui depuis
tout à l'heure et c'est de détruire mon
lancement elle ne va pas y arriver
regardez les coulisses du casting
tu es anorexique ah non mais tu es
orthorique ah non mais là tu souffres de
TCA c'est vraiment vraiment chaud au
bout d'un moment les gars je vous le
remettre dans le contexte c'est comme
aller dire à quelqu'un en surpoids ou à
quelqu'un qui souffre d'obésité tu es
gros ah bah oui non mais tu es vraiment
très très gros non mais alors va
peut-être falloir manger moins en fait
un moment donné je sais pas genre pour
moi c'est vraiment la même chose ok
c'est la même chose parce qu'on
s'adresse vraiment à deux personnes qui
sont en souffrance alors pas pour les
mêmes raisons mais deux personnes qui
sont en souffrance qui sont en
souffrance physique en souffrance
psychologique et ça n'a aucun sens
d'aller dire à quelqu'un tu es ta ta en
se disant ah non mais je l'ai alerté
c'était bienveillant ben moi ça n'était
pas en fait